for longer and Ortiz look for a safe
spot to watch the trail and wait in a
few minutes illegal crossers may emerge
from the brush and start making their
way north is Cal more like a
hide-and-seek you know that Mouse King
after dark the rules change drug
traffickers can ambush agents without
warning and many will be armed the
closer you get to the to the border the
more brazen they get the men get an
urgent radio message a large group is
spotted heading directly towards them
but the other agents lose sight of them
well the last place they had is right
around here just south of us now they
could re-emerge anywhere and Berlanga
and Ortiz are sitting ducks now they
know where they going we don't
agents Berlanga and Ortiz are patrolling
the remote Sonoran Desert and a large
group of potential smugglers is heading
their way
Chris bara here all they can do now is
take up positions and hope they
intercept them as they pass by well we
make lot of noise and at this time noise
travels sound travels along long ways
and that's we're walking as a group they
can hear us if they're lead up we got
couple avicii set up and now money just
about to get on before take it start
pushing their sign and hopefully pushed
us individually towards us we're longer
and Ortiz can't see or hear anything
moving through the darkness so dispatch
calls in help from above Oscar Peru and
his black box team well the photo camera
picked up
that's where
right now it's a pretty tough area to
work cause you got all those uh rolling
hills and Canyon with help coming from
the Blackhawk team above agents on the
ground start moving toward the spot
where the group was last seen but the
trails gone cold but looking for right
now is trying to pick up some sign that
would tell me Seaver the Cooper's
actually come in this direction and if
so we can communicate with the agents I
let him know that I direction of travel
but I'm leaving I'm not able to to pick
up the sign right now yeah you get a
good facial over from the air should be
here any time now
all right so we're dock at that shabam
suddenly Peru spots someone hiding under
a grove of trees a half a mile from the
agents on the ground
oh yeah there's everybody there buddy Oh
now you said you got eyes on
here come here to dream I can shove it
up
forty's and Berlanga race to the
location from other directions agents on
horseback do the same
all right the horses are coming down
there right up
soon all the agents converge at once and
the group has no choice but to surrender
agents from the south and from the north
I mean edges basically is coming from
all possible directions I mean were
eligible kind of like you know box a man
and apprehend him in the body wrap this
is a whole group football better than
see anybody break off they're not drug
smugglers but a group of 18 illegal
immigrants who've been travelling for
almost a week
asta la pierna de Bono
no tiene documentos de Mira quien para
estar aqui no I just talked to them
basically told me they're from Mexico
there have any immigration documents to
be here the United States so hold on
that we won't find out the whole story
until it's taken back to the station